all right y'all we have time for One
More Story on this Martin Luther King Jr
day and it's a really important one this
is what I'm
watching it's easy to think the Life and
Legacy of Martin Luther King Jr are the
distant past but that's not the case
today marks what would have been his
94th birthday and his work continues to
this day to emphasize that point his
only grandchild is still a teenager
she's also an activist and author just
like her grandfather her latest
children's book is we dream a world here
to talk about it is Yolanda Renee King
give it
up
hello welcome to the show and
congratulations on this is such a cool
achievement thank you so much and thank
you for having me absolutely so tell us
about the book so the book is well it's
a children's book and it's inspired by
um the late Langston hughes's poem um we
dream a world which actually um
interestingly enough inpire the I Have a
Dream speech and it really shows using
imagery and poetic language the type of
world that we can have and the type of
world that I think we talk about so much
but we forget what that looks like and
so I think that this book will really
give kids and and really honestly
families a visual of the type of world
that we can have absolutely we always
need reminders right absolutely um so
how do you plan to honor your
grandfather's Legacy today so my our
organization my family's organization
the drum major Institute we're actually
um working on launching our service
initiative today because 5 years from
now for the um 100th birthday we are
trying to um obtain 100 million hours of
service Across the Nation so today is
the launch of our new service initiative
that's
incredible well yol's latest book we
dream the world is available right now
and everyone is going home with a copy
you're all getting one
thank you so much elanda I'm liking your
post right now and that's not all our
season long partner pilot pin makers of
G2 the goto pin and the Kelly Clarkson
show support the ongoing work of your
family so they're going to be riding the
drum major Institute a check for $1,000
just to help out how's it
sound thank you so much Yanda thank you
to all our guests this our ciao Amel
colan Woodson Jr and Kings return have a
great day y'all and if it's not try to
[Music]
[Applause]
Chang thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home